[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and after we just made
a video yesterday about rumors for your
night season 2 I did not think that we
would have to make another Yuri a nice
video anytime soon but we just got
massive news this morning about Yuri
Anais and we just have to put it out
there we have to let you guys know this
morning on the official Yuri a nice
Twitter account it was announced that a
Yuri a nice live-action adaptation is in
production this is just huge news and
not only that but a short teaser for
this live-action film has just been
leaked online also this morning I'm just
gonna play the teaser for you right now
I'm not going to waste any more time and
then after I will analyze it here we go
[Music]
Wow
that was just beautiful I mean I believe
that this this actor will be portraying
Yuri Kazuki in the live-action no okay
sorry I'm sorry no I'm just getting word
that this gentleman will actually be
portraying Victoire nikiforov in the
live-action adaptation but I mean so
graceful beautiful I want to thank my
good friend Mackel not for finding this
teaser for me this morning and sending
it to me right away maca knot is a great
guy and he is probably the biggest fan
of Yuri on I stand I've ever met in my
life so yeah we got news about the
adaptation we got the teaser leaked but
that's not all we also received some
news about the potential plot line for
the yuria nice live-action adaptation
apparently in the film there will not be
a same-sex relationship between the Yuri
and Victor instead they will both be
competing for the affections of a female
Romanian figure skating coach played by
Scarlett Johansson now I personally love
this new creative direction but I would
love to know how you feel about it let
me know how much you love it down below
so yeah just massive news this morning
the fans are excited they can't believe
it it's crazy if you like this video be
sure to LIKE and subscribe and if you
have any issues with this video be sure
to contact Mackel not I will leave the
link to his channel in the description
and until next time see ya cows space
boys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]